but but why are you leaving you I'm a
free agent now Luneberg yes one way or
another your stash brother Steven will
look after you now we'll be in good
hands through balls
she'll be right well I must be going now
time for me to test the market farewell
Kevin now I do what I want
I know you and Russ had your issues but
I can assure you there will be no such
chemistry problems here well that's nice
to hear
plus you'll have the services of the
premiere point guard in the realm wait
so better than Steph Curry well
certainly top three
well there's Russell crisp org top three
point guard in the East is what I meant
okay modernist Kyrie Irving's of Kairos
gotta be number one and then Kyle Lowry
keeps pretty good these days and Isaiah
Thomas honestly I'm ready if you want
him to play here or not well I'm just
being honest though you would honestly
I'd be top three easy my max contract
shooting guard wasn't owned injured oh
so sorry John I put my 40 on the line of
this to see you waiting shut up as I was
saying the chemistry here definitely top
five in the in East
[Music]
so what's that what's that over there
that box so works and sorry sits soul
box show box so bucks so like a box full
souls when you sign this for your soul
and your personality are put into the
box right so do I get it back
indubitably haha so what are your
thoughts on tanken oh it's true if you
were to join us we'd be endlessly
ridiculed your old teammates will
despise you and the fans in Oklahoma
will cook their stew on the flames of
your burning Jersey people will call you
a traitor
a coward and some may say you've
destroyed the entire balance of the
realm but on the other hand if you were
to join us we would be so good this is
for you but we will win not just one
championship not to LeBron
I'm sorry I you might want to read this
and this weight not spray its concerns
and changes next year if this is about
Delhi going to the box I think we'll
live not for what
well what one is fine some people never
get Championships and and we should be
happy with this one
[Applause]
[Music]
well we're all very excited to have you
here but I must warn you the GAR pact
has eyes everywhere
be careful what you say and let your
game do the talking have no doubt I'm as
healthy as ever and I shoot threes now
there's no reason we can't form a super
team here it is you who is that it
something you know Mario Chalmers we
used to play together in Miami oh great
here we go hello Rio
no your honor balls now oh that's so
weird we was on a super team together
the big four remember those days Dwyane
no but I can't blame me for leaving
really Twilight of your career bad knees
bad shoulders maybe you can scrape
together one last playoff run with sorry
what's your nice Jimmy Butler Oh
you do look a lot like Michael Jordan
well it's all very exciting Matt we must
be going now I'm afraid oh all right
well if you need to pour God or whatever
just send me a raven yes we are Grande
Oh
oh well you never know with him he's a
bit you'll definitely need a veteran
backup now we have plenty of depth but
we'll keep you in mind could you know we
could be a super team again by Rio you
can yell at me all you like I don't mind
alright well I guess I'll head to
Cleveland
[Music]
can't you come in come in I came to say
hello and welcome you to use them ah why
thank you
and you must be the no scouting
apprentice I've been expecting you
I am you're starting shooting guard
James Harden all realm shooting guard
James James you sir when would momently
[Music]
James Harden the point guard looking
shooting I've been studying your game
it's marvelous brilliant really
/ that's very kind of you to say so you
have a lot of books I see this whole
shelf is inbound place is baseline
sideline I also keep ISO plays in there
somewhere for no good reason really
and this shelf here all books on the art
of the top over there this tempo playing
picking rolls you name it
feel free to borrow them as you clean
Holloway I bet you need whole new
library just for all defensive plays
defense like you know and the team has
the ball and it to no score on oh no no
no no none of that here it's a waste of
energy and it's no fun I say half the
defense sample the
five minutes Melo understood so CLE
Carmelo seems all my last friend and
Knicks colors quite the opposite
actually the whole city cheers your name
outside these garden walls I saw what
they did to you more like what I did to
them it's not right
you're a legend I'm just an old enforcer
when I saw out of front office treat you
well I do what I always does
I'll stand up for bass players
especially against Thompson runners out
these days well I'm here to return the
favor
no come on we don't have much time for
you mean were you doing we're getting
you out of here we guarantee the key
toss it now
Oh tokine starik we had to go your
family issue was sticky oh yeah well I'm
tossing
[Music]
[Applause]
a prayer
[Music]
good do you have uh it's game dawn it's
early for sure but if the season ended
today we'd barely be in the AC do you
want to be in the AC I know that we
don't want that
I don't what they see no I don't want
that we are the paces of Indiana right
we don't settle for the AC sir Reggie
Miller have settled for the 8th see her
with Jermaine of Neil have settled for
the 8th see good Mark Jackson or Rick
Smith have settled for the 8th seed hey
Smith we are not an ACD veteran are we
will not be a 7c team that I see is much
better than our records I see a fifth or
sixth seed see who will at best make it
to the second round but some please no
further
okay with that right now our defense is
4050 leagues let's get that up to 15 and
are often its 20th this is that up to
maybe also 15 let's go out there and
send those Pistons back to Detroit and
questionnaire never ceases regulatable
[Music]
what's going on Shh
it's the trade deadline this could be
our ticket out of here why would you
want to leave me in line for the first
pick no not because that fool Billy King
traded to Boston a few years ago why
inodes they're coming to come and got
back up everybody back up
I'm sorry to announce we have made a
trade
Oh young it's going to washing foul ball
sorry oh my god they're like say what
wins yes 34 wins 34 oh man there's like
so many wins I know you're disappointed
but pack your bags they expect you there
on the morrow right right oh yeah I'm
very sad this is sauce I'm very sad but
I'll go back now and fight all the tears
I love all you guys
thanks Lord Commander any other trades
to report or no fair now come on it's
time for practice tomorrow we lose to
the No
[Music]
[Music]
how those their house magic what are
they doing here we don't plan for a full
night what do you want we want to
propose a trade well we don't need a
trade work intended oh come on now
you're fifth in the East you're worse
than the Hawks right now don't you want
to compete with the cab well right
what are you got Serge Ibaka
he shoots dunk and he's an elite rim
protector he's everything you need
isn't that right Serge I defend anyone
is there LeBron alright okay well what
do you want for in demar derozan
no heat my friend very well worth a shot
then give us Norman pow
no he's too young
boom also your friend Raj Norman trying
to make a trade here I am also with Fred
all right all right well then what else
do you have to offer will give you can
we treat drink I don't think so no what
about Terrence what about Terrence you
can have Terrence Ross well what does he
do he's like an older Norman no no
Terrence you like in Orlando it's warm
let the man speak Terrence what do you
do well I'm a pretty good 3d player
though some people might call me and
consisted so maybe I'm not a good three
declare and how you are I am a good
three indie player oh and a decorated
doctor worried certainly inconsistent
throw in a draft pick and it's a deal a
draft pick fine
but then you got to give us something
else too something else
all right we'll give you a choice you
can either have mario hezonia or this
horse well what is Mario do he scores
three points again and what does the
horse - it's a book it's a horse it
walks around with people on it I don't
know
does horse things make it was the fifth
pick in the draft he's pulled the gun
potential this horse will take the horse
[Music]
we'll look you it is the brow and a foul
just ignore them Detroit get under your
skin
oh how cute is there in it look at him
they're like close it in his eyebrows
looks like boogie cousins has a boogie
brother
I don't know there I'm bit scared I mean
with this chemistry they've got I think
they've got a real shot of the 10th
season you know are you talkin uh for
someone who has less rebounds at his
point off your DeMarcus if you get a
technical you'll be suspended again I'm
sorry
we're being rude I am actually a big
admirer of your game I love the move
where you fake left roll right and then
get ejected you know for being a big one
he put off that fancy little stash so
far and your froak you are working on
your somebody's don't worry oh he's
right enough of this king of the frame
of approval while we're bickering about
eyebrows and mustaches Golden State is
marching towards the championship save
your energy for the real fight by Sal
with Golden State technical foul oh come
on you are became the raffle what
disembowelment of a referee which the
league is sort of cracking down on now
do you like it here in Dallas very much
so better than Golden State Golden State
is a very special place dear to my heart
but I'm very happy here in my new home
but don't you miss being a contender I
have a much larger role here thanks to
the graciousness of our law ah
Nerlens I almost didn't recognize you
without your cylindrical hair it is an
honor to present my king Lord mark of
House Mavericks kiss me child
Thank You Harrison we're delighted to
have you here please sit
would you like a rib no thank you I'm
not very hungry
Oh child you can't come to Texas and not
enjoy some barbecue okay
you like their lives very good
there Chandler Parsons favorite thing to
eat when he was here oh you must be
thirsty
where's the sweet where's the sweet tea
but don't just stand there you imbecile
get up Sam sweetie now I know things
were difficult for you in Philadelphia
I'm very grateful for my plows success
happened it's dreadful in that chamber
part of a franchise now come on you can
be honest with me I'm not like those
other owners you know I'm a cool guy
just a normal cool gas notice well if
I'm being honest there were a lot of
centers and not enough minutes frankly I
was very sick of losing their child
there's no need to worry anymore
here in Dallas we never tank a chin-up
aren't you excited to play with Dirk oh
yes she's very good he is the greatest
yeah he's great the great test the
greatest you seen Ellen's I personally
ensure that no one makes light of my
ethics or else or else what
after my sweetie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he is close my lord excellent thank you
[Music]
inside aya kanai
it's time Sam I just need a moment
they say an analytics man doesn't have a
heart but I ran the numbers and nothing
could be further from the truth
you are son to me Joelle now that I will
always be watching you I will always
believe in you please forgive me for
leaving I have no choice um open the
door you will be the light that pulls
this city from the darkness the fruits
of the process was soon ripened and
harvest will yield great things open the
damn door pinky get the battering ram
and no matter what you must always Oh
[Music]
trust the power remember make sure they
hold onto rather coveted note and
athlete amethyst only take the Bella
Terra Bella
Mallory fear everything maintains long
[Music]
[Music]
Michelangelo's nothing damn Philadelphia
fans always so angry they should be
grateful I got a first round pit for
Nolan okay fine toppy team protected but
saml Hosea the family could breach the
castle wall it's going to be fine father
Oh Kapoor's guarding the door holding
the door hold the door hold the door oh
the door Okafor Okafor Okafor
yeah galore can yo hey guys the beads on
a table
yo paint a picture of you and NVIDIA
right here
[Music]
good evening as reigning world champions
and with that Eastern Conference
champions
we welcome the representatives from each
of the Eastern playoff houses to the
annual feast of the east to kick off
this year's playoffs so please beef
oh my god look at the boy girl so many
wings hope Terrance is happy and that
Lyon Casey was pre-printed you took the
whole what are you staring at that pot
of gold behind me there are some rock in
my teeth no I'm just looking at the
second best team in the big balls for
such a small man dwarf yeah yeah I've
heard it all before it's too short
you can't play defense hell he isn't
even the best Isiah Thomas but somehow
this dwarfs been scoring 30 points the
game hit and cook shuts and health Celtx
owns the number one seed when his
tournament's over
you're all gonna look up at me and
you'll know there's a new king in the
east
this again didn't we do this last year
we've got chemistry and the debate to
take you down don't sleep on a to see
more dear King for a North will soon
rule to eat we are the new kings of the
eat this again didn't we do this last
year 60 wins countin it puts us in the 1
seed and our house goes 12 men deep we
are the Spurs of the east
tell em Korver bird man bomb this year
there will be a new king of the east
we're doing this again
you're on your last leg LeBron there
will be a new king in the east and this
time I mean it here for you literally
did this last year the era of poor
George raw Heather and how stasis begins
now verticality there will be a new king
in the East we're doing as they say
you're sitting can't be big but we got
the original big boy and I say anything
is possible
Katy was wrong it's not true
nothing is possible there's no point in
trying
LeBron wins the East every year we
should all be thank you the playoffs are
trapped they're gonna beat us all it's a
trap without a cap
okay
and
[Music]
playing in the paint I see it's my
favorite place to draw fouls why are you
still here I thought your Bannerman les
long ago do you think they can make it
home without you to carry them over a
quick duel James one-on-one just like
old times I don't have time for your
games Brodie some of us are still in the
playoffs you're right
I'd hate to break those second most
valuable ankles before your next series
I am coming to my car so with so much
Asafa do your worst [ __ ] very nice
a double sham guarded to the answers
crossover impressed
actually that was gym hallways oh sorry
I was supposed to let you get the
rebound right now this move here I used
it for my 22nd triple da [ __ ] I use this
one for my 42nd I don't know why you
don't come to Houston more often you
clearly love to travel
oh this from a man who leads the league
in turnovers not anymore
[Music]
[Music]
game point James time to show off those
renowned defensive skills
ah but actually my defense is much
improved in fact if you look at the
numbers you will see that I contested
over 8 shots per game third most amongst
guards Oh father Foyle we could have had
it all James if you and the serpent
hadn't slithered away okay Ross
like this isn't what you wanted all is
all to finally be done man or the triple
Dobbs the realm MVP now he does what he
wants right
everything except tween now if you
excuse me I have to get my ass kicked by
the Spurs and get his ass kicked
they did though sir beard and his
bannermen won the first battle how Spurs
proof two strong language in-house
Rockets in six games elsewhere in the
West House Warriors made quick work of
the brotherhood with one banner and sent
house he has his swift demise
when the pop king in the soulless army
tried to stop them
that um Silva was no match for gold over
in the east the hammer of Akron smashed
rebellions from house paces and Canaan
links all eyes turned to the one seat at
the king of the fourth who merely the
king of fourth place
and so it was written King James and the
champions of bowlers against the most
powerful house the realm has ever seen
okay well maybe second second Oh sir
obviously it's Sir Jordan is 96 Bulls
well some say it's the balls but others
argue it's the Showtime dynasty right
here in Los Angeles the again Lord magic
I want to become a dynasty well the
first step is to trade all the little
buggers from sending appropriate even
then we signed big-time free agents Oh
little George and thirdly we build
through the trap
[Music]
from the fire you are for my little
nozzle the triad of Falls will make the
realm shake closely and get us our 1
million gold
[Music]
my lord
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]